alors vous revenez je sais pas si vous
êtes encore là ou en route en tout cas
vous revenez de la région vous êtes
allés à Baie-Saint-Paul évidemment à
Saint-Urbain mais parlons d'abord de ces
recherches qui se poursuivent pour
retrouver
Christopher Lavoie et Régis Lavoie les
deux pompiers volontaires c'était
terrible c'est des gens qui voulaient
aider une famille
où on en est dans les recherches on
continue on va continuer encore combien
de temps monsieur le ministre
on va continuer tranquille le faudra
monsieur il faut il faut garder espoir
sur ouais c'est des moments extrêmement
difficiles je suis allé voir la mairesse
je suis allé saluer le chef des pompiers
des premiers répondants je suis allé
saluer des collègues je leur ai dit de
garder espoir on va faire on va mettre
toutes les ressources disponibles à
sauter du Québec où il saviez les forces
armées téléières la Garde côtière est là
et plongeurs de la Sûreté du Québec on a
travaillé jusqu'à très très tard hier
soir pour longer les berges donc je
garde espoir je garde espoir qu'on va
retrouver c'est ces deux personnes
différentes donc ce soir demain vous
avez les équipements les ressources
comme vous avez dit les forces armées
vous aident aussi on va mettre le paquet
pour tenter un miracle si jamais ils
avaient été
envoyé sur une rive ou je sais pas
il le faut il le faut c'est notre devoir
pour pour les familles pour les amis
j'ai survolé la région pour me rendre à
Saint-Urbain avec avec le maire de blé
Saint-Paul et la député carrière de
Bourassa c'est un constat qui est
troublant bon le maire a dit on croit
qu'on analyse le niveau de l'eau et tout
ça on croit que le pire est derrière
nous alors ma question la 138 à quel
moment vous pensez qu'on va pouvoir la
raccorder la réparer
on discutait tantôt du côté des mesures
de coordination avec les cellules de
crise le MTQ était présent est toujours
présent oui un premier viaduc qui est
qui est ouvert c'est celui c'est celui
du pont Leclerc il reste le pont la mort
le pont la 138 donc Saint-Urbain est en
partie isolée encore mais vous avez des
images là que les gens peuvent voir
représentement c'est là que les roulotte
on frappé une portion du viaduc le
niveau d'eau est encore très élevé donc
les ingénieurs du MTQ nous disent que
niveau devra baisser pour être capable
d'aller travailler vous avez même encore
un poteau le titro-québec qui est en
plein milieu en plein milieu de la
rivière donc le niveau devrait être plus
bas pour sécuriser le secteur pour
commencer des travaux on va faire tout
un autre possible pour être capable de
sécuriser le réseau et de reconstruire
cette portion de route le plus
rapidement possible comment ça et je
vous le pose de façon très naïve comment
ça prend le temps reconstruire un
tronçon comme ça qu'est-ce qui vous
disent vos experts une fois que l'eau
avoir baissé une fois que le niveau de
l'eau aura baissé cela peut c'est
difficile à évaluer tout dépend des
conditions est-ce que le viaduc devrait
être fait au complet là où on voit une
portion qui est endommagée et là les
ingénieurs devront aller vérifier si le
restant de la structure est sécuritaire
ou non parce qu'on doit tout défaire
est-ce qu'on doit recommencer ce qu'on
peut réparer seulement une portion il
est un peu de prématuré pour moi le de
vous dire de quelle façon les ingénieurs
vont évoluer cette situation donc si on
doit tout refaire est-ce qu'on prendrait
que cela va prendre beaucoup beaucoup
pour apprendre un peu de temps on est
conscient que c'est la saison
touristique qui va démarrer bientôt le
camping genévrier ben écoutez c'est
connu par beaucoup beaucoup de gens au
Québec qui me disent que l'été il y a
près trois 4000 personnes sur ce camping
donc on veut te retrouver une certaine
normalité pour eux puis de leur redonner
espoir le plus rapidement mais il faut
le faire de façon sécuritaire et logique
c'est un magnifique endroit en effet en
terminant monsieur bonardel les
municipalités demandaient genre c'est le
Congrès demain qui commence de lui MQ
comment demander deux milliards de plus
vous le voyez sur le terrain vous
les besoins sont énormes pour solidifier
nos routes nos ponts nos réseaux
d'acqueduc les infrastructures en
général c'est une une épreuve collective
va falloir faire face à la facture de
tout ça
on peut pas se cacher des de la
situation des changements climatiques on
le vu depuis 2017 les inondations
majeures on a vu la même chose en 2019
on a vu les tempêtes on a vu Fiona qui a
frappé les Îles de la Madeleine dans
notre plan pour une économie verte on a
près d'un point de milliards sont
disponibles pour les municipalités et le
Premier ministre et moi nous étions du
Québec en mars dernier pour annoncer un
premier 70 millions pour supporter les
municipalités qui oui on le sait qui on
est peut-être pas les ressources
fiscales pour être capable d'épauler de
protéger leur berge et de protéger des
résidents qui vivent dans leur maison
près du fleuve ou non depuis des
décennies qui veulent garder leur maison
alors on est conscient de la situation
on met les sommes pour pour préserver et
prévenir au lieu de guérir et là-dessus
on doit s'adapter les ingénieurs doivent
doivent se prévoir aussi c'est cru ces
eaux additionnelles ces tempêtes sont de
plus en plus fortes c'est pas simple
mais on est on est présent pour pour
supporter nos municipalités pour en
donner plus que le 1,2 là pour peut-être
arriver aux 2 milliards que demain
il y a quand même majeur cela prendrait
quand même un certain temps pour que ces
municipalités se préparent s'adapte il y
a une portion qui est payante par ces
municipalités le gouvernement a fait une
grande grande part donc on est conscient
les enjeux sont importants mais c'est
une somme quand même qui est conséquente
et importante pour les supporter merci
de nous avoir parlé monsieur bonardel à
la prochaine merci beaucoup au revoir